là c'est très joli sa grande en cochant
au camp ma mission va le reconnaître
et ici on a quand même un menton qui est
assez impressionnant avec c'est quoi
c'est un haut parleur sur le banc ouais
pourquoi parfois les pensées liam est un
haut parleur ici sur le bas pourquoi pas
ça permet effectivement d'avoir du son
stéréo en haut en bas
why not
[Musique]
or rien ne va plus rien ne va plus j'en
ai partout aujourd'hui deux nouveaux
colis sont arrivés au studio de nouveaux
colis plutôt cool
le tout premier s'ensuivra parler d'ici
quelques jours je vous parle de plus en
plus de maison connectée de solutions
pour la maison pour la guitare j'ai
connecté
et qui dit maison connectée dit ce n'est
connecté donc ça c'est une sonnette de
la marque caring plutôt cool parce
honnête c'est pas une sonnette en fait
je m'exprime halles c'est pas une
sonnette c'est les mecs je parle de
sonel ding donc non c'est pas une année
c'est beaucoup mieux qu'une sonnette
c'est une interphone un interphone pour
la maison on vous appelle sur votre
smartphone vous pouvez répondre à
distance
il ya pas mal de choses et ça c'est
intéressant donc ça on va le détailler
d'ici quelques jours
ça c'est quoi cool cool cool premiers
produits reçus tous tombés rien ne va
plus et deuxième colis qui a été reçue
tout à l'heure qui est super cool ce
sont elles les nouveaux google pixels
alors là on a les petites coques et
pixels on a donc deux smartphones qu'on
va regarder le pixel 3 et les pixels 3xl
sans oublier bien sûr le plus de salles
ce temps quelque part par là qui est là
donc l'idée aujourd'hui
là c'est avec gêne d'arrivée ce matin
donc c'est de les ouvrir deux les zones
boxer de regarder un petit peu comment
ils sont faits est-ce qu'ils sont de
jolis pas jolies boucles les ai déjà vus
donc je peux vous le dire je pas la
foulée du design mais néanmoins ses
smartphones sont assez énormes parce que
même si google a eu un design hyper
sobre ils ont été hyper loin du point de
vue software de ce qu'on peut faire avec
et c'est vraiment tout l'intérêt de ces
produits il faut savoir que google
pixels c'est la première fois qu'ils
arrivent en france jusqu'au pic celle de
l'année dernière est absolument aucun
produit qui était vendu en france donc
il fallait les faire venir
donc on avait pour l'instant absolument
pas parler donc c'est une toute première
fois que je vais pouvoir tester des
smartphones de google je suis très
content donc que d'ici quelques jours on
va cesser ses smartphones et on va faire
d'ailleurs m bien plus que ça puisqu'on
va répondre à la question quel
smartphone achetés entre le google
pixels 3 pixels 3xl mais pas seulement
mais y vint promeuvent un iphone 10r
mais c'est pato ont le + 6 t donc là
pour moi on a quand même quelques gros
gros gros gros smartphone du moment et
la question se pose forcément dans tous
ses smartphones quels sont les points
positifs que négatifs de chaque
smartphone
donc au lieu de vous faire des failles
tient un nouveau pic seule 3gs mais
devint pro vs lui vs lui ensuite ils se
mélangent en sortira 15 vidéos qui au
final ça serait invivable on n'y
comprenait rien on va faire une seule
grosse même vidéo pour tous ces
smartphones qui ont chacun leurs
particularités leur fausse leurs forces
leurs faiblesses et on va en parler
alors on fera un gros gros gros gros
comparatif à la fin pour l'instant on va
faire simple on va en boxer les pixels
3xl 3xl le pixel stands on allait
regarder on va regarder ce canon la
boîte on va regarder si google a fait un
très bon boulot au niveau du packaging
on à les allumer et on voit sont
arrêtées là
et d'ici quelques jours on sortira lé
test et je vous dirai au final ce que je
pense réellement de ses pixels 3 pixels
3xl est arrivé n'est pas au bout de nos
surprises
un petit peu de off regardez ce truc
tous les cartons qui a ici je sais même
plus où les mettre là il y en a au
dessus il y en a en dessous il y en a
plein donc là tous les côtés il y en a
ici
de ce côté aussi d'ailleurs s'en va en
parler d'ici quelques jours
c'est franchement cool c'est un carton
que j'ai reçus avec plein de produits
philip sion objets connectés donc la
maison connectée on est en plein dedans
vous allez voir on va se faire plaisir
là il ya tellement de tous les côtés que
je ne sais plus quoi faire je ne sais
plus de quoi parler mon dieu c'est
horrible
la première chose le packaging alors
packaging relativement sobre à la google
direct franchement à la google sobre
simple mais efficace
là les petites couleurs de côté et
j'adore les couleurs j'adore vraiment ce
choix de couleurs qui était fait par
google c'est vraiment hyper hyper hyper
joly c'est hyper sobre par rapport à
d'autres à d'autres boîtes
c'est très très google franchement c'est
très très très très google vous voyez la
différence entre le pic seule 3 et 4
auxerre qui forcément plus grands et ce
qui est bien réussi sur le packaging est
ce qu'on voit aussi sur des smartphones
comme apple c'est les ouvertures qui
sont complètement facilité facilité à
l'arrivée donc on prend on our pascaline
d'un autre côté il y en a une autre de
l'autre côté forcément il ya sa petite
soeur qui est là je l'apprends jours
c'est vraiment hyper hyper simple sommes
pas plus pour l'instant
ensuite
exactement la même manip sur le modèle
xl
je prends je tire avec amour avec amour
délicatesse volupté toutes ses copines
voilà voilà ça c'est plutôt cool donc
voilà un tintin tintin
waouh très beau c'est très particulier
c'est très particulier ceux qui lisent
haguenau vaudois là on va vraiment dans
le dans le point de détail 1 vraiment
levé le petit bord là qui dépasse le
packaging est bien fait et ça change un
petit peu de ce qu'on a l'habitude de
voir sur des smartphones somme toute
assez classique et donc là on est sur le
pixel trois petites languettes pour
l'ouvrir là au puc salle 3 bien avec
nous dévoile toi sympathique très
sympathique et c'est marrant ça l'espèce
de papier un peu un peu maths c'est
assez assez rigolo je tire bien et bien
voilà nous avons et si le pixel trois
formats hyper pratique il est pas très
grand c'est vraiment cool patrie
vraiment très facile à prendre en main
on trouve très très facilement le
capteur d'empreintes digitales derrière
la grosse caméra que vous allez parce
que ce double pixels vous n'avez pas de
double optique le mode portrait et
logiciels et ici il ya forcément un zoom
numérique mais format vraiment hyper
cool mais l'exercice avec le modèle xl
on prend ou tir vient par la montre
qu'il a peint alors forcément il est
plus grand mais on trouve également très
très facilement le capteur d'empreintes
digitales derrière bon on va l'allumer
d'ici quelques instants je trouve très
réussie alors je sais pas si vous aviez
déjà vu ma première vidéo lors de la
présentation des google pixels 3 vous
avez ici une partie un peu plus matin
touche un peu plus mat pour
effectivement éviter les traces de
doigts éviter qu'ils salissent et comme
la partie du haut n'est pas censé être
touché par les doigts sauf tout de suite
quand je le fais vous avez un côté très
brillant alors moi je trouve ça vraiment
très sympa dans un bus scolaire vous
avez des petits bords légèrement arrondi
smooth elle dessine sa le souligner on a
l'impression que c'est un petit module
qui sort du dessus c'est assez bien fait
vous avez ici la petite partie bridant
tacle google très joli j'aime beaucoup
ce côté bien côté un peu sapin un peu
satiné un peu soyeux c'est vraiment
sympa prise en main sympa bon après
c'est assez sobre franchement vous allez
si le petit bouton de couleur pour venir
l'allumé bouton de volume de l'usb type
c'est en bas ici votre tiroir de cartes
sim sur l'autre côté absolument rien sur
le dessus ça va être le petit micro si
je veux pas dire de
bêtise et mesdames et messieurs je crois
que c'est tout c'est vraiment hyper
sobre ensuite à l'intérieur de la boîte
alors botte du pixel 3 passes et 3 100
ça va être la même chose on a à
l'intérieur
hop donné là les amis c'est quoi c'est
une doc j'imagine on a ici de quoi
ouvrir son tiroir de cartes sim
ça nous indique bien et si vous avez une
seule carte sim qui est là c'est parti
c'est-y pas mon lapin donc là vous avez
pas mal d'informations un autocollant
google et un autocollant typique selma
fois sympathique et qu'est ce qu'on à la
presse qu on a va qu'est ce qu'on a là
on aura des informations d'ordre général
d'ordre réglementaire
voilà c'est cool suite qu'avons nous
nous avons ici à barvaux commencé par
tirer là à eau alors ça c'est bien fait
jamais ce petit côté packaging la voyais
très soignée avec la petite languette
qui va venir se libérer la wah wah wah
wah wah des petits écouteurs intra
auriculaires c'est pas mal ce petit
format
c'est très rigolo ce sont des écouteurs
en usb type c'est ici vous l'avez
remarqué
il n'y a absolument pas de prise jack
néanmoins ce qu'il coule ce qui
forcément bien réfléchi vous êtes un
bouton ici pour rappeler google
assistant bravo comme un pas deux prises
jack google était très sympa de nous
mettre un adaptateur usb type sévère
prise jack
ça c'est cool on a ensuite à l'intérieur
un petit adaptateur usb type à vers usb
type c est ici votre câble de recharge
ici nous devons avoir ici j'imagine elle
est forcément voilà votre blog de
recharge usb type c'est pareil sur le
secteur ça c'est cool
nous avons exactement je suppose la même
chose de l'autre côté c'est ça tout à
fait la même chose sur le modèle xl donc
en terme de packaging
c'est tout pareil
là c'est très joli sa grande en cochant
au camp ma mission va le reconnaître
et ici on a quand même un menton qui est
assez impressionnant avec c'est quoi
c'est un haut parleur sur le banc ouais
pourquoi pas les pensées bien mettre un
haut parleur ici sur le bas pourquoi pas
ça permet effectivement d'avoir du son
stéréo en haut en bas
why not pendant que la recherche de
mises à jour sont en train de se faire
sur les deux smartphones d'ailleurs
c'est marrant je passe il voyait bien
celui ci un côté un peu plus rose et
celui là est un peu plus blanc pendant
ce temps de regarder les coques parce
que j'ai reçu ici deux coques de
protection une pour le xl qui est là et
une pour la version normale c'est pas
mal le système se sauve pas en bas pas
mal c'est assez sympa alors la deuxième
cette fin il a souvent comme un tiroir
forcément c'est plus grand c'est
sensiblement la même chose et c'est pas
mal côté très doux coté matière c'est ça
que j'aime beaucoup dans ces téléphones
c'est je trouve qu'il ya vraiment un
travail sur la matière qui a été fait et
points courses on le retrouve également
sur les coques c'est plutôt plutôt bien
pensé ça c'est un truc est super
intelligent de la part de google
on utilise son ancien smartphone pour
transférer sur le nouveau sauf que là où
plein de marques le fond parle claude là
vous le faites directement par le câble
donc ça c'est vraiment vraiment
intelligent
là j'ai mon iphone 6 aces je branche hop
avec le port light ni et ce petit
accessoire que j'ai à l'intérieur de la
boîte du pixel je le prends ça hop je le
branche comme ça ça ensuite je viens
brancher directement dans mon pixel
ce qui fait que j'ai d'un côté mon
iphone prêt à transférer sur le pixel 3
et là je vais transférer directement par
calcé ira beaucoup plus vite c'est
vraiment hyper bien vu et très
intelligent de la part de google
bravo pendant que le pixel 3 est en
train de bosser de l'autre côté là on va
regarder ce qui se passe du côté de
pixels 3xl première prise en main super
cool d'un point de vue purement
esthétique s'envole détaillé lors du
lors du test mais d'un point de vue
purement esthétique c'est vrai qu'on le
look et pascal de plus de plus actuel et
de plus moderne et le plus léger
si vous comparez un one pu assister vous
avez signé toute petite encoche c'est
vraiment un travail qui a été fait d'un
point de vue design est encore là vous
avez une coquille assez grande
là dessus
une encoche qui est très grande c'est
vraiment un choix qu'a fait google de se
dire voilà non on n'a pas un smartphone
hyper fin avec des bordures hyper fine
on préfère mettre en avant l'expérience
utilisateur et je pense que le fait
d'avoir mis et ses deux parlant là n'est
pas là par hasard
alors je suis encore un peu largué au
niveau des gestes il ya plein de choses
qui me manque vraiment je me familiarise
avec voilà la salle et un guide toute la
navigation par jesse voilà donc la up
la non là s'annonce pas bon alors
comment je fais pour avoir voilà donc là
j'ai toutes mes applications qui sont
déjà pré installé c'est vrai que
l'expérience sonore est énorme mais
c'est vraiment pousser le volume à fond
il ya un volume qui est complètement
dingue ont tous à en voir par ailleurs
du test je voulais vraiment juste un
petit coup d'oeil dès le départ c'est
vrai que le fait d'avoir mis ses deux
haut parleurs en façade c'est vraiment
pour l'expérience c'est vraiment pour
l'immersion et c'est vrai que c'est
plutôt pas mal
je pense que l'adn de spring seul pixel
3xl une pixels c'est vraiment
l'expérience utilisateur qui est
complètement privilégiés par rapport au
design du produit et s'en va le détail
et dans la prochaine vidéo test qui va
arriver très très très prochainement à
l'intérieur on a aussi le pixel stands
alors le pic certes on va en reparler
également leur espace du test il vous
permet de recharger vos smartphones sans
fil et vous permet aussi d'utiliser
votre smartphone de façon un petit peu
particulière je garde le suspense pareil
et très bon boulot en terme de packaging
d'ouverture regarder il souffre comme ça
waouh ça c'est vraiment hyper hyper
chouette à petit pixel stands on te
déshabille certes un peu ce pas la
brasse touche et c'est très rigolo alors
c'est tout blanc sur le chrome ça j'aime
bien si tu saoules alors là c'est pareil
on va venir enlever ça ça s'enlève waouh
c'est un objet qui est très drôle parce
qu'elle quand on regarde comme ça et
qu'on sait pas ce que c'est on peut se
dire mais what the fuck c'est quoi ce
truc
alors ensuite à l'intérieur qu'est ce
qu'on a à a exactement la même chose
petit guide petite info très pratique
on a ensuite ici le bloc d'alimentation
le câble de charge qui se situe là et on
a fait le tour de la question
voilà pour cette découverte des
nouvelles pixels 3 pixels 3xl on va en
reparler très rapidement on va beaucoup
en parler parce qu'à vraiment beaucoup
de choses très intéressantes à dire du
point de vue matériel du point de vue
logiciel du point de vue utilisation et
puis on va se poser la question comme je
voulais dit en préambule quel smartphone
acheté entre ben déjà c'est google
pixels 3 pixels 3xl que vous avez là
entre eux les huawei mais devint promet
grain savoir lequel acheter on va se
pose également la question du wan plus
ce système qui rase parfois extrêmement
récent qui est aussi un smartphone qui
est vraiment excellent j'utilise en ce
moment en tant que téléphone principal
est la question par rapport à la f10
faire tu es vraiment des smartphones
d'actualité dans cette gamme de prix
donc on va les prendre tous les quatre
et on va est mélangé de tous les côtés
puis on va regarder ce qui est
intéressant oui non voilà donc je vous
invite à faire une chose pour savoir
tout de google pixels 3 mpixels 3xl
c'est bien évidemment de vous abonner de
rester connecté parce qu'on en parle et
très rapidement d'ici là soyez ça je
vous embrasse
et puis vous marquez tout en commentaire
vous dites ce que vous en pensez comment
vous les trouvez bien oui non d'un point
de vue design est ce que vous êtes déçu
du boulot google est ce que vous êtes
contente du point de vue logiciel est ce
que vous les avez déjà ses smartphones
est ce que vous avez acheté vous marquez
tout ça et on sera un plaisir pouvoir en
discuter ensemble
merci à vous et à très bientôt sur yahoo
[Musique]